hi I'm Anthony Fisher with Reason TV and
I'm speaking with a I'll press the
author of the book beautiful Souls
saying no breaking ranks and heating the
voice of conscience in dark times it
tells the story of a few ordinary people
who risk their careers reputations and
sometimes their lives to break with the
majority and do the right thing can you
talk about where the title beautiful
Souls comes from sure beautiful souls is
actually a Hebrew expression it's your
fame nefesh and it sounds as I fear the
title at first glance sounds a little
hokey and a little sort of honey-coated
Oh everyone would surely want to be
called a beautiful soul in fact it is a
term of derision in Israel it's sort of
a synonym for bleeding heart and the
soldier I write about comes to has a
crisis of conscience in which he fears
that he's being viewed as a beautiful
soul as though this is something
negative
most of the beautiful souls depicted in
the book don't get a Hollywood ending
they're not celebrated for doing the
right thing and often they lose
everything it's kind of a dismal final
analysis and not a great advertisement
for bravery what do you think motivates
people to maintain their individual
righteousness at any cost any honest
depiction of that is not going to be in
a sense the Hollywood version of the
story where the person who defies these
things is thanked for it again getting
back to the title the reason I chose
that title is because I want to bring
across to readers that these are people
we have a very easy time idealizing when
they're very far away from us when they
say no to other unjust laws the ones
that we don't our selves comply with but
when people who resist or question or
don't conform are closer to us when we
find them in the same workplace we're in
or in the same neighborhood we're in or
in the same country we're in then it
becomes much harder to you know to
admire them they tend to be scorned and
vilified there's a sequence of stories
in the book and in the first story
you're in the context of world war 2
where I think is for Americans people
are so familiar here with you know just
following orders they think of Germans
we all think of German
and how could they have followed orders
in fact we all follow orders most of the
time in our lives we all adapt fit in
conform the last story in the book is
about a financial broker who works at a
firm where everyone around her is
conforming and adapting to the
management directives which is to sell a
fraudulent financial product and and one
broker there the one eye profile Leyla
Weidler doesn't do that but we shouldn't
just think that oh this is this is
something that Germans or Japanese or
Rwandan do it's a huge force in in in in
every modern society the Milgram
experiment is used as an example several
times in the book of how ordinary people
can be compelled to do evil things when
they feel like they're complying with
Authority can you briefly explain the
Milgram experiment and how it applies to
the subject of your book sure I actually
think the Milgram experiment has been
misunderstood and I tried to convey that
in the book a Stanley Milgram brought
ordinary Americans into a laboratory one
person in the experiment was the learner
the other person was the teacher and the
teacher was told every time the learner
answered a question wrong to shock the
person to go one voltage up on a mock
shock machine the learner getting these
shocks was an actor so this was actually
a test of conformity what Milgram
expected was that very few people would
continue shocking the person to very
high voltage until the learner passed
out and screamed two-thirds of the
subjects in the experiment went all the
way and this was just startling to
everyone and it has led people to think
well human beings are mindless
conformist they just go along or maybe
they're sadists worse right they just
they get these orders they don't care
that they're just mindlessly doing this
if you read the actual transcripts of
what transpired in the labs or read
Stanley Milgram's own excellent book
about his experiment what he says and
what the transcripts show is that most
people didn't want to go along and
indeed they resisted but there were
prompts that Milgram used to get them to
go further and those prompts were very
successful and one of the most
successful ones was to tell the person
you are not responsible for the
suffering of this person I'm responsible
I run the experiment don't worry about
it and Milgram in a sense captured this
thing we all do which is
shift the responsibility for our actions
to some someone above us in the chain of
command maybe someone below us in the
chain of command or maybe just you know
this is the way the world is and in that
way reconcile doing things that we
actually think are wrong that to me is
the genius of the experiment it's a dark
message but it's not as hopeless of
messages I think people people who know
very little about it think thanks so
much I'll press author of beautiful
souls for reason TV i'm anthony fisher